皆さんこんにちは
[音楽]
YouTuber歴今年で11年目はじめ
しゃちょーです
Youtuberという歴史を駆け抜けて
きてはや11年
長かったですよ初めてYouTubeを
やり始めたのが11年前でしょうもう記憶
にない初めてですはじめしゃちょーです
こんにちははじめ社長ですこんにちは
はじめしゃちょーですこんにちははじめ
しゃちょーですこんにちは
しゃちょーですこんにちははじめしゃ
ちょーですこんにちははじめしゃちょー
ですそもそもその頃YouTuberって
いう言葉もなかったしYouTubeに
動画をあげることが仕事にできるとも思っ
てなかった本当になんとなくで
YouTube始めて気づいたら
YouTuberって呼ばれてたみたいな
人間なんですけどもはじめ社長も長い歴史
があるわけですよこのYouTube市場
においてこの長いはじめ社長の歴史におい
て私
グッズというものをですね何回か出させて
いただきました購入していただいた皆様
ありがとうございます本当にはじめした
ところの11年間で波はありますけども
そこそこ人気にこうなんかよくも悪くも
なんか今もいい感じになんとか生き残って
て
応援してくださる皆様のおかげで11年
続けさせていただいておりますありがとう
ございますたまにあのアンチみたいな人に
オワコンって言われますけども本当の
オワコンはオワコンと言われることすら
ねえから名前が出る時点で生きた
コンテンツなのでそんな今をときめく生き
た化石のはじめしゃちょーたくさんの
グッズが出てるんですけども
メルカリで売られてるんですね
なんと悲しいことでしょうはじめしゃ
ちょー僕のグッズがメルカリで売られてる
んですよこれ僕に限ったことではなく
いろんな人も誰でもそう自分のグッズが
メルカリとかこうなんかオークションとか
で売られたりすることよくあるんですよ
ちょっとメルカリ見てみようと思います
はじめ社長
原作
[音楽]
なるほど
ですねパッと見ると結構畑のグッズとかも
あるなはじめしゃとのグループっぽいかな
グッズ結構買いやすいと思うんですけども
今回はちょっとはじめしゃちょー飲みに
絞ってちょっと見てみますねどんなのが
あるんだろう
あこれとかはじめしゃちょーの畑のはじめ
社長ガチャガチャでしか手に入らない
はじめしゃちょーのアクスタキーホルダー
かな1000円ですねなるほどいいねあ
これはですねはじめしゃちょーとデュエル
マスターズっていうカードゲームがコラボ
した時に出た
百獣世界の研究者はじめしゃちょー
エンジェルコマンドとビーストフォーク
はい実はデュエマにもなってるんですよね
いいねやす300円でもっとやりやすい
これも懐かしいねはじめしゃちょーの
YouTuberの日常っていう漫画も
出させていただいたことがありましたね
これあの別に宣伝じゃないですけども
めちゃくちゃ面白いんですよ1巻と2巻で
600円か方法方法
600円ぐらいかなるほどなはじめて社長
3位
いるよマジうわ
懐かしい
懐かしいこれゴットって書いてあるこれ
ロケットの僕のTシャツですね天才的な
センスうわマジでサイン入ってんじゃん
おいマジかえ俺サインしたの売られてんの
俺が自分でサイン書いたチェキがなんと
1万円で売られてますね
ふざけんなよせっかく俺がさあ
恥ずかしがりながら寝顔をさ
チェキで撮ったやつをさ売らないで欲しい
んだけどこれ多分世界に1個しかないやつ
だよファンクラブのプレゼント企画で当選
したものですスリーブに入れ保管してまし
たあ大事にしてくれてたのでありがとう
ございますうるさと売るな初めて社長
フォトブック
卒業大学の卒業のタイミングで調子乗って
作った写真集ですね
めっちゃ一重だな
奥二重これ整形とかしてないんですけど今
二重になっちゃってるんですけども
だんだん2人になってきましたね
999円か
辛いなうわポッキー君と一緒に撮った
プロマイド写真のセットですね
懐かしい
一緒に海行かないかって書いてあるえー
これ結構盛れてたのになぁ売っちゃうのね
そういうことしてるんだ
[音楽]
結構セットになって1400円とかですね
まじか同じ商品がたくさん売られてると
ちょっと凹むけどでもなんか一品一品と
いうかそんなにたくさんうーわー俺と所沢
のパペットのぬいぐるみも売られてる
500円マジかこれHIKAKINさんと
か俺とか東海オンエアとかのサイン全部
込みのやつが9万8000で売られてるよ
ひどいなあ待って待って俺これ普通に
サイン書いてるやつ売られてないこれ
古いやつですよ俺のサイン常に変化し続け
てるんでこれ古いやつだからみんな買わ
なくていいですよ声になるとマジでサイン
書きたくなくなるはじめしゃちょーの文房
具セット2000円あでも何個か売れて
ますねちょっと嬉しいえ2018年に
スマホケースに書いた詐欺が売られてる
大門二度とスマホにサインインしません
こういうことされるんでしょうだって俺も
リゾートさんにしませんよいや写真集とか
結構もうレアだからなそこそこうわーこれ
攻めたな
合計1万円で売ってるな
価値は高い気がしますもうないから公式
プロマイドうわーこれ海の家の店員さん
熱だ1440円なるほどね値段が結構
すごいね上限がティッシュどうなってるん
かな俺がチャンネル登録者数1000万人
いくために売ってたティッシュあでも結構
減ってるな今これしかないですね見当たる
のが
減った減ったうわ
夏真面目パーカー
懐かしいめっちゃ昔真面目って書いた
パーカーを売ったんですけどめっちゃ本当
がおしゃれで結構人気だった記憶がある
いやこんなの売っちゃうのね4500円ん
そういうの敷地なんで
関係なくねはいという感じで売られて
仕方ないものもかなりあると思います
YouTuberも11年もやってくると
やっぱり古いグッズとか使わないであろう
ものも絶対増えてくるからまあ気持ちも
わかるけどサインしたものを売るのは
ちょっとさ俺その人のためにサインしたの
にちょっと心が
ぎゅってなっちゃったねうんというわけで
今こういう感じではじめ社長のグッズが
かなりメルカリとかで出回ってるわけなん
ですけれども今回何をしたいかと言うと
はじめしゃ社長
メルカリに売ってる俺のグッズ全部
買い占めます
[音楽]
[拍手]
希少価値向上はい今言った通り今からです
ねメルカリに売ってるはじめしゃちょー
関連のグッズを全部買い占めます自己回収
です元々取ればあの俺が考えたものだから
いいでしょこれ初めて社長のグッズ
買い占めることによって何が起きるかと
言うとはじめしゃちょーグッズの
価値が
上がるんですよええ
突然はじめしゃちょー系のグッズが
どんどん売り切れになっていくとこう見
てる人はえ何何えっはじめしゃちょ来てる
今真っ先に出るのこれ
上がっちゃうっつってもうどんどん
どんどん
値段が上がっても大変なことになっちゃっ
てえーちょっと売られすぎてるはじめしゃ
ちょーグッド自分で買ってはじめしゃ
ちょーグっての希少価値は爆上げしようと
いう自分の勝手に上げ企画です買うものの
決まりとしては俺だけ
初めて社長単品のグッズのみ買い占めます
あとはじめ社長のサインが書いてあるもの
は一切買わせて頂きませんだってその人の
ために書いてあげたんだからはいという
ことで結構グッズありますねTシャツ文房
具ピンバッジ何これ売ってんだ誰だエルモ
は全然知らないよだけど今からメルカリの
グッズ全部買わせていただくので果たして
何円になるのかそしてメルカリに売られて
いるはじめそのグッズどれぐらいの量が
あるのかちょっと見てみたいと思いますで
は買いまくって届くまでしばしお待ち
くださいバイ
というわけでメルカリではじめしゃちょー
グッズを全部買い占めてから
約2週間ぐらい経ちました結構昔に出品さ
れた人とかいてなかなか発想に時間かかっ
て約2週間ぐらいで無事にはじめしゃ
ちょー全部買い占めることができたんです
けども見てくださいこの量
すごい数ある
調べて買うのにもすごい時間かかったし
その部分にもかなり時間がかかりました
そんなメルカリで売られてるはじめしゃ
ちょーって全て全部1個ずつ開けていき
たいんですけども送っていただいた方の
住所とか名前が書いてあるのでちょっと
開けるところは見せられないんですけど
ちょっと全部開けていきたいと思いますで
は
[音楽]
かなり多いなかなり多いなはいというわけ
で開封してみました
皆さんたくさんの出品ありがとうござい
ますありがとうございますでも思ったより
たくさん俺のものが売られてるないやでも
これ作戦通りですからこれでメルカリに
おいてはじめしゃちょーグッズの大量
買い占めによりはじめしゃちょーグッズの
レア度がグーンと上がりもう
プレゼンつきますからこれで俺のグッズの
価値上がるでしょうちょっとはじめしゃ
ちょーグッズどんなものが売られていたの
かちょっと見ていきたいと思いますうわ
懐かしい懐かしいしこれ多分絶対
潰されてたよなこれぐらいなんですけど
ちょっと
つぶでこれ確か何だっけなはじめしゃ
ちょービッグぬいぐるみ当時俺こういう
なんか
宇宙柄の服を着てた時期があってそれを
グッズ化してもらったビッグぬいぐるみ
ですねこれが確か限定からこれレアですよ
こんなでっかいぬいぐるみを売ったことも
ありましたね昔はバリアンと岡崎っていう
名前を付けさせて頂いたはじめしゃちょー
とスピンズのコラボグッズですね確か
めっちゃ可愛くないこんなかわいいのを
よく売れたなこれちゃんとのびて裏にね
なんか
ケースとかも入れるというとっても可愛い
クマ2匹売られてました
[音楽]
落ち込んじゃってますね
懐かしいこれこれサイズ全然俺切れないな
多分Mサイズですねはじめしゃちょー始め
と真面目をかけた真面目パーカーですね
これでこれが社長パーカーだ真面目
パーカーと社長パーカーを確か売った気が
するこれもMサイズうわすごいなんか人の
服買うとなんか色んなお家の匂いがするぞ
真面目社長パーカー結構たくさんあります
ねうわでこれが確か
ゲーセンで取れるはじめシャツを指人形
みたいなやつですこういう俺なんか色んな
髪色にするからこれ確か黒の時かな黒髪の
時の俺がすごい数売られてましたね全部
買い占めさせていただきましたこれを
ちゃんとマジの商品タグまでついてます
これあこれ昔髪の毛を赤と青の半分にした
時があってその時のやつですねこれ結構
少なかったな所沢のちっちゃいバージョン
のことわざわっていうこの指人形3個これ
俺のチャンネルの昔のエンディングのなん
かキャラクターの指人形も6匹ぐらい出て
ましたこれもゲーセンだったかな
可愛くない俺なんか若い時こういう髪型し
てたんだよな偵察に俺の顔が印刷されて
いるというかなり豪華な仕様になってます
これがめっちゃ多かったねここら辺全部俺
のこの人形ですこんだけ売られてたって
ことはこれだけ変われたってことだから
これすごかったんですよ多分それのクマの
コントローラーバージョン
センスあるな
めっちゃ可愛くないここにも社長パーカー
これ嬉しい真面目社長Tシャツとパーカー
もあるんだMか
Lだったらマジで欲しかったそれめっちゃ
新品ぽくないいいなこれ俺M切れるかな
全然M切れるあちょっと普通に使える
服は使わせていただきますねまたこれも
何かの記念で作ったやつだ私ははじめ社長
ではありませんパーカーですこう初めに
社長ではないよっていうのを言いつつも
はじめしゃちょーのパーカーっていう
の考えていたんだ畑のメンバーとかで出て
たやつの俺のこれも全部買わせていただき
ました1個だけ色が違うなこれレアなのか
なすごい数あるよ全部買いました写真集
です
懐かしいなこれ大学の時の
こんなことしてた写真集何
冊あんのこれ40冊以上ありません43冊
ぐらいこの奥にありますは第2弾ですね第
2弾の写真集です
[音楽]
こっちの方がちょっとこなれてるな個人的
には第2弾の方がちょっとイケメンな感じ
はしますね
[音楽]
買わせていただきました50冊ぐらいあり
ました帰ると熊がいるデュエマのカード
たくさん売られてました全部買いました
懐かしいなんかトミックさんの顔と俺の顔
をボールにしたっていうマジで悪ふざけ
グッズを昔えーグッズで販売してそれも何
個か売られてましたね
すごいな結構ね売られてるのねこれ買い
ました
登録者1000万人目前ティッシュ配りの
ティッシュはいまだに売られてましたうわ
懐か
[拍手]
[音楽]
イベントでなんかくじ引きみたいなやつ
コンビニでやっててそれのラストワン賞
ですねラストショーがこれです
悲しいことになる4つぐらい売られてまし
た将来的に100万円行く予定なのに
昔俺が作った僕鞄っていうカバンですね
美的センスを感じます俺が考えたゴッド
バックねロケットおじさんのバッグです
真面目TシャツまだあったこれはUFJの
始め社長のTシャツかなちょっと似てない
100日後に死ぬワニの人が記念で書いて
くれたはじめしゃちょーTシャツです
色違いバージョンもあったんですけどそれ
もピンクとか売られててデューフェスの
やつゴッドTシャツのしましまのやつこれ
まじ売っちゃうこれ俺今も来てるけどな
もらうね普通に普通に着るねこれもう
社長Tシャツ
社長Tシャツ100日後
[音楽]
夏
めっちゃ昔作ったかTシャツ昔の
エンディングのやつ
あめっちゃいい匂いの柔軟剤使ってるわ
絶対女の子だうわ夏やっぱこれ俺が大学
卒業した時に作った記念Tシャツですこれ
ブラジル
卒業しましたって書いてあります結構あり
ますね
イケメン私がゲーム実況者のポッキー君と
一緒になんかカフェした時のやつですね
普通にこの時ちょっとちょっと美女いいな
海の家のお兄さん風のやつですね頭
なでなでしてもらっちゃってこれね
可愛い
社長のエンディングのキーホルダーうわ
始めるの限定のバンカーリングも売られて
んだけど入ってくれてありがとうなんか
バンカーリング系結構ありますね昔のやつ
とかポッキー君のカフェの時のキー
ホルダーあゴッド缶バッチロケットおじ
さんのやつうわすごいカフェの時のこの
なんか飲み
ブサ俺飲み物に引くやついろんなの入って
ますね
可愛いメリークリスマス始めるの
めっちゃいい匂いするやつだこれ
クローゼットにこうやってかけておくと
いい匂いする始めの限定のグッズです初め
の限定やっぱ売っちゃうのねこれも始める
のシャーペンですね始めるというはじめ
しゃちょーのファンクラブがあるんです
けども年間で入っていただくとそういう
なんか限定グッズとかが届くので皆さん
是非入ってくださいはじめしゃちょーの
ビックリマンシールみたいなあー未開封の
俺の声ですねうわーこれちょっと待ってよ
これ富山県さんとさ
富山県警察とさその安全に気をつけて
欲しくてはじめしゃちょーリフレクター
これ確か配布したと思うんですよね俺の
記憶が正しければ反射台つけて交通安全を
守ってあげようと思ったのにそれを売っ
ちゃうかなうわっ始めるクリスマス
缶バッジですはじめしゃちょーの缶バッツ
これ初めての限定のラバーストラップです
可愛いこれは俺のイケメンプロマイド消し
ゴム文房具とかも結構売ってたなイオン
さんとコラボした時のスマホループリボ
ンっていうスマホにつけれるリボンです
YouTubeリマインドというイベント
した時に配布されたお面文房具ねはじめ
しゃちょー君の文房具とかまあ缶バッジも
ずらずらとありますね本当にすごいな
はじめしゃちょーグッズの数なにこれ
非売品の俺の写真
透視の俺のアクリルキーホルダー4つ
ぐらい結構売られてるなうわなんかね
色んな出しすぎて俺もうね記憶が曖昧なの
よこれ結構
盛れてるな何だろうこれスクール
カレンダーフォトブックフォトブックです
ね俺の結構売られてるのは結構結構買い
ましたぞ
筆箱
筆箱とかもすごい量あるんですよこういう
ねノート系とかですねたくさん売られて
ますで可愛いこれメモパッドこれははじめ
のフォトブックレットツアーだこういう
はじめの限定グッズって見せていいのかな
これでも結構盛れてる
ホスト風のカットとか
こういうのとかあるんですよこういうのが
たくさん書いてあるファンクラブ限定の
フォトブックですこれこれもねファン
クラブのイベントで全国回ってた時があっ
たんですけども全国各地で写真を撮った
やつがこういうフォトブックになったって
いうそういうなんかアイドルっぽいのも
あのファンクラブでやってた時がありまし
たはいファンクラブ系はやっぱり少ないな
大事にして持ってくれてる人が多いと私は
ちょっと信じたいですクリアファイルとか
もかなり売られてるなおいおいおいこれ
始めるおい始める
ぞ俺のファンクラブの証を売りさまとる
やつがある
すごい数のグッズ売ってるなぁ
懐かしいこれ昔俺が血迷って作った動画
をっていうカードゲームですね自分で
カードを作ってた時もありました
懐かしいなこれこれもファンクラブ限定の
ポーチです
可愛いこういうの得点でもらえたりします
これもユーフェスのグッズですね
服の色どうしたでここら辺全部漫画ですね
はじめしゃちょーのYouTuberの
日常っていう漫画が4巻ぐらい出てるん
ですけどもこれもかなり漫画だからかな
結構たくさんの数売られてましたこれね
めっちゃおもろいんですよ個人的にたまに
見返したくなる見ます
漫画はかなりありますねイオンさんとの
コラボのクリアボトルですねえ可愛い
じゃん普通に可愛いちょっと使わせて
いただきますあとはもうこういう時計とか
かなはじめしゃちょーグッズの時計がもう
何個か売られてたり
天国大魔境ねこれおまけでつけてくれてた
人がいるんだよありがとうなあのこれ
始めるのは限定のタオルですねタオルも
すごい量売られとるでこれがあと
クッションとTシャツかなまざっくりと
こんな感じでしたはいというわけでメル
カリに売りさばかれていたはじめしゃ
ちょーグッズ根こそぎ全て買い占めてみ
ましたはじめしゃちょっとだけのグッズを
全部買わせていただいた結果セット売りし
てる人もいたから多分トータル400個
ぐらいあると思います金額なんと
[音楽]
32万7221円でございました
YouTuber11年やってきてやっぱ
いろんなことがあっていろんなグッズを
出してきました中には俺の記憶にないよう
なグッズもあったしうわなんかこういうの
出したなあと思って
ちょっとなかった反面こんなに売られたの
かと思ってちょっと
粛々ってしましたうん別にいいんですけど
自分の
グッズにいやいやもったいない
[音楽]